enfin le prix médicis étranger a été
décerné à l'italien umberto eco pour le
nom de la rose
c'est le premier roman de ce très grand
écrivain italien donc qui a 50 ans et
qui était surtout connu pour ses
ouvrages théoriques de sémiologie et de
science des signes le nom de la rose
c'est son premier roman donc il a situé
au 14e siècle et il explique pourquoi à
monique atlan qui l'a interrogé tout à
l'heure le vent et la gt une époque
affolés par la signification plus que
nous même si nous avons la télévision le
téléphone
chaque élément de la réalité de la
nature a été lue comme s'il y avait une
situation hallucinatoire dans le port où
je raconte cette attitude inverse
lessines était un train de celle ci
c'est comme mon personnage fait on
commence à interpréter les signes d'une
façon c'est moi dire moderne les signes
et naturelles rrn on était plus dans la
dans l'état d'âme symbolique mais il ya
des autres personnages qui sont encore
d'un saut c'était adam donc je me
trouvais un choisi sens de but du 14e
siècle de situation assez intéressant
entre sur le clivage entre deux univers
et de façon de lire le monde mais on est
toujours le monde même aujourd'hui comme
un livre est il aisé de passer de
l'écriture d'essayiste à celle du
romancier ah bon avant de commencer le
roman je ne croyais pas d'être capable
d'écrire un roman
ce n'est pas un corps dit d'ailleurs
mais à et j'ai l'impression que tous mes
essais théoriques sont écrit comme un
roman c'est à dire avec les goûts de
metron public les phases de la recherche
est donc probablement les jours que
j'avais avec un roman je devais faire un
roman avec une structure policière parce
que je crois que toute recherche à une
structure policière même
livres de philosophie aux livres
d'histoire et pensez vous que cette
expérience romanesque puisse renouveler
votre votre approche des questions
théoriques ça je ne sais pas exactement
un tant que théoricien des questions de
communication littéraire j'avais écrit
beaucoup sur la narrativité avant mais
je dois dire que l'expérience directe
m'a donné des idées
enfin il faut toujours faire des
expériences pour comprendre mieux
quelque chose des idées qui sont pas
tellement différents des délits des
précédents mais elle m'a éclaircies
certaines choses par exemple le fait que
un roman n'est pas avant toi fais
d'écriture verbales mais est en fait des
constructions de monde et après avoir
accueilli mon roman
j'ai été poussé à lire le roman d autres
pour voir comment avant tout il y avait
là la construction d'un monde
d'où le choix linguistique de couler